[Musique]
nous nous souvenons qu'il était assis ici
avant de devenir président
Il faisait ses courses à l'épicerie mais
un président de la personne que vous connaissez
ça nous rend fiers d'avoir un premier ministre
C'est pourquoi nous en sommes fiers
être l'un de nous
[Musique]
match de football
Son seul passe-temps est le football, même son père à peine
Haci Baba n'aimait pas qu'il joue au football
jouer au football même marié
chaussures et un tel secret d'ici
s'enfuirait vers le terrain de balle
[Musique]
mes enfants ont grandi ensemble
Prenez le petit déjeuner ensemble et jouez à Gezer
sa femme n'est rien comme ça, alors qu'est-ce que c'est?
Je sais que tu sais que ça entre comme chez nous
allons-y
Je veux dire, je le jure, que ferait-il ?
chose
il y avait des saucisses Elif dans la comptabilité
devenu le gérant de l'endroit, nous avons fait un salaire de 500 lires
nous avions l'habitude de l'appeler chef, chef maintenant ok
ça ne change toujours pas Ha maintenant tu ne peux pas t'approcher
Gardes, ce couloir de police ?
ça ne s'approche pas ou tu l'as vu tous les
tout a une fin
Les gardes les gardes se retirent tous
je mourrais pour
d'accord?
Pour lui mais comment je le connais
parce qu'il y a quelqu'un
[Musique]
belle famille Notre quartier tout le monde
savoir ici
il n'y a pas de distance, non, c'est comme un voisin alors
[Musique]